Bonjour à tous!
Aujourd'hui, à l'occasion des championnats du monde
d'athlétisme qui se sont terminés il y a quelques jours,
je voudrais vous parler du fameux record
du monde du saut à la perche.
Quand j'étais môme, je ne comprenais pas pourquoi les perchistes
ne prenaient pas tout simplement des perches plus longues.
Je veux dire, s'ils prennent une perche de 8m,
ils devraient bien être capable de se débrouiller
pour sauter 8m avec.
Et bien non, en fait, pas du tout.
Aujourd'hui, on va voir pourquoi au saut à la perche
comme dans d'autres disciplines d'ailleurs,
ce n'est pas du tout la taille de la perche qui compte.
♪ [Générique] ♪
La manière la plus simple d'analyser la physique du saut à la perche, c'est de penser à l'énergie
Si vous voulez vous élever d'une certaine hauteur,
vous avez besoin d'énergie pour vaincre la pesanteur.
Et il existe une formule qui permet de calculer l'énergie
dont vous avez besoin. C'est m x g x h
h c'est la hauteur à laquelle vous voulez vous élever
m c'est votre masse et g l'accélération de la pesanteur,
9,8 mètre par seconde au carré
Quand un perchiste veut sauter à une certaine hauteur il a donc besoin d'énergie
et il va trouver cette énergie
principalement dans sa course d'élan
Parce que quand on se déplace à une certaine vitesse on a de l'énergie,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'énergie cinétique.
Là aussi, une formule très simple permet de calculer l'énergie cinétique
c'est un demi de m fois v au carré.
v c'est la vitesse du perchiste, m c'est sa masse.
Donc pour calculer l'énergie cinétique dont dispose un perchiste grâce à sa course d'élan,
il faut connaître sa vitesse.
Je ne connais pas exactement la vitesse de pointe d'un perchiste,
mais en gros on sait que un sprinter court le 100 mètres en à peu près 10 secondes
Ce qui fait une vitesse moyenne de 10 mètres par seconde.
Evidemment un sprinter va avoir une vitesse de pointe plus élevée que ça,
mais d'un autre côté les perchistes ne sont pas non plus des sprinters,
et ils doivent se trimballer la perche.
Donc on peut faire l'hypothèse que un perchiste en vitesse de pointe, il est en gros à 10 m/s.
Si on met ça dans notre formule (10 m/s), et qu'on suppose que notre perchiste fait 80 kilos,
on trouve une énergie cinétique de 4000 joules.
Maintenant on peut se poser la question : "Avec cette énergie cinétique
jusqu'à quelle hauteur le perchiste peut-il espérer monter?"
On va supposer qu'il n'y a absolument aucune perte d'énergie,
c'est-à-dire que toute cette énergie cinétique est utilisée pour s'élever.
Si on met 4000 joules dans la formule (m x g x h)
et qu'on suppose que notre perchiste fait toujours 80 kilos,
on trouve une hauteur de 5,10 m.
Vous voyez que ce n'est pas mal du tout puisque 5,10 m
c'est le bon ordre de grandeur des sauts qu'arrivent à faire les perchistes.
Il y a quand même un petit problème dans ce raisonnement, c'est que je vous ai dis :
"ça, c'est si on suppose qu'il n'y a absolument aucune perte d'énergie"
c'est en quelque sorte le saut parfait.
On trouve 5,10 m et on sait que aujourd'hui le record du monde est à plus de 6 mètres.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
La raison,
c'est que les perchistes ne sont pas
ponctuels.
C'est pas des points, ils ont une certaine taille.
Donc le raisonnement qu'on vient de tenir s'applique au centre de gravité.
Pour un être humain qui se tient debout, le centre de gravité est environ à 1 mètre du sol.
Grâce à l'énergie cinétique,
le perchiste peut élever son centre de gravité de 5,10 m
donc si le centre de gravité est à 1 mètre sol ça fait 6,10 m.
Là vous voyez qu'on est quasiment au niveau du record du monde de saut à la perche.
Alors, il y a quand même un élément qui est très important dans cette affaire,
c'est que au moment où le perchiste passe la barre, il a un mouvement d'enroulement.
Ce mouvement d'enroulement permet que le centre
de gravité du perchiste passe
au niveau de la barre voire légèrement au-dessus.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas besoin que le centre de gravité passe 1 m au-dessus de la barre.
C'est assez analogue à ce qu'on trouve en saut en hauteur.
Vous savez, en saut en hauteur,
le saut en "fosbury" est beaucoup plus efficace que le saut "en ciseaux".
La raison, c'est que sur un saut en ciseaux,
vous êtes obligés de faire passer votre centre de gravité
plusieurs dizaines de centimètres au-dessus du fil,
alors qu'avec un saut en fosbury,
le centre de gravité passe juste au niveau du fil voire légèrement en-dessous.
Donc élever son centre de gravité de 5,10 m, ça suffit pour passer 6,10 m.
Il faudrait rajouter quelques petits détails,
comme le fait que un perchiste peut se donner un petit supplément d'énergie
en poussant sur ses bras sur la perche au dernier moment, etc...
C'est quand même remarquable, qu'avec juste quelques considérations de physique générale,
on arrive à retrouver, presque à 10 cm près, la valeur du record du monde de saut à la perche.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Alors quand même, dans cette histoire, pour l'instant je ne vous ai toujours pas parlé de perche,
j'ai juste fait des raisonnements basés sur l'énergie.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la perche, dans cette histoire?
Pour comprendre, il faut revenir au cas du saut en hauteur classique.
Le raisonnement que je vous ai tenu, on pourrait imaginer qu'il s'applique aussi au saut en hauteur :
on a une certaine quantité d'énergie cinétique et on s'en sert pour s'élever dans les airs.
Sauf que vous voyez que ça ne marche pas du tout, puisque le record du monde de saut en hauteur,
il n'est pas du tout à 6 m, il est à 2,45 m.
C'est à peu près la hauteur d'un filet de volleyball ou bien d'un but de foot.
Ce qui fait qu'au saut en hauteur, on n'arrive pas à atteindre des hauteurs aussi élevées qu'au saut à la perche,
c'est le fait qu'il y a plein de pertes d'énergie,
c'est-à-dire qu'on estime que l'énergie cinétique,
il y en a à peu près seulement entre un tiers et un quart qui est utilisée pour s'élever en hauteur.
C'est pour ça que les gens qui font du saut en hauteur
arrivent à élever leur centre de gravité de seulement un peu plus d'un mètre,
alors que les perchistes arrivent à élever leur centre de gravité de plus de 5 mètres.
"bruit de foule"
"Récord del mundo!"
Pour comprendre pourquoi la perche et la technique du saut à la perche sont si efficaces
par rapport au saut en hauteur classique,
on peut imaginer ce que serait le saut en hauteur si on utilisait en plus
un petit trampoline ou un tremplin de gymnastique qu'on placerait à la fin de la course d'élan.
Je ne connais pas votre record personnel au saut en hauteur,
mais je suis quasiment persuadé que vous l'exploseriez
si on vous mettait un petit tremplin de ce genre.
Pour quelle raison? A priori, un petit tremplin comme ça, ça ne crée pas d'énergie.
C'est tout simplement que un tremplin ou un trampoline
permettent de bien mieux convertir l'énergie cinétique de votre course d'élan
en énergie pour pouvoir vous élever.
Comment ça se passe?
En fait, si vous sautez sur un trampoline à la fin de votre course d'élan,
il y a un moment donné où vous n'avez plus d'énergie et vous avez tout donné au trampoline,
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où vous êtes le plus bas dans le trampoline vous êtes quasiment immobile
donc vous n'avez plus d'énergie cinétique,
par contre le trampoline, lui, il est complètement tendu donc il a accumulé toute cette énergie
sous forme de ce qu'on appelle l'énergie élastique.
Et ensuite, quand le trampoline va se détendre, il va vous rendre cette énergie,
mais d'une manière plus verticale donc qui vous arrange plus pour ensuite vous élever dans les airs.
Donc le trampoline permet de bien mieux convertir l'énergie cinétique de la course d'élan.
Et bien une perche ça fait exactement la même chose au saut à la perche,
et ça le fait de manière quasiment parfaite,
c'est-à-dire que, à la fin de la course d'élan, le perchiste plante sa perche,
il y a un moment donné où le perchiste est quasiment immobile,
par contre la perche est complètement tordue,
ça veut dire qu'il a cédé à la perche toute l'énergie de sa course d'élan,
la perche a accumulé cette énergie sous la forme d'énergie élastique (du fait qu'elle est pliée)
et ensuite la perche va se détendre
et va rendre au perchiste cette énergie, mais cette fois dans la direction verticale,
et ça va lui permettre de s'élever dans les airs.
La technique de saut à la perche et la structure des perches sont tellement bien optimisées
qu'aujourd'hui elles permettent de faire ça de manière quasiment parfaite,
c'est-à-dire quasiment toute l'énergie cinétique de la course d'élan
est transférée dans la tension de la perche,
et ensuite la perche resitue cette énergie de manière quasiment parfaite au perchiste
dans la direction verticale, lui permet de s'élever, et donc de passer la barre.
Ce qu'on voit c'est qu'aujourd'hui les sauts à la perche sont quasiment parfaits du point de vue de l'énergie,
et donc la hauteur atteinte est quasiment aux limites de ce que permet la physique.
Cela veut dire qu'il est assez peu probable qu'un jour le record de saut à la perche soit complètement explosé.
Même si demain quelqu'un arrive avec une nouvelle perche
faite dans un matériau extraordinaire,
ou que quelqu'un invente une nouvelle technique de saut révolutionnaire,
comme ce qu'il s'était passé avec le fosbury en saut en hauteur,
et bien ça améliorera peut-être un petit peu le record
mais ça ne va pas l'améliorer de 40 cm
parce que on est déjà aujourd'hui aux limites de ce que la physique peut faire
et le saut à la perche est déjà un saut quasiment parfait.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo!
N'hésitez pas, comme d'habitude, à la partager, pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne.
Merci infiniment à tous les tipeurs qui me soutiennent sur Tipee.
Sachez que vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur facebook, sur twitter,
et aussi sur mon blog qui s'appelle Science étonnante.
Merci, et à bientôt!